auf den bergen ist freiheit
der hauch der größte steigt nicht hinauf
in die reine lüfte so schwärmte einst
friedrich schiller die alpen als letzter
hort von freiheit und demokratie
bis heute ein gern gepflegtes idealbild
doch das war nicht immer so gefürchtet
waren die alpen seit jeher als
lebensfeindliche gegend eine kaum
überwindbare grenzen für den menschen
rheuma und schmuggler gingen aus
wirtschaftlicher not voraus beschwerlich
gar lebensgefährlich ihr weg durch die
felsige einöde undenkbar damals dass die
menschheit später beim anblick von
schnee gebirge in verzückung geraten
könnte die alpen raum kulturgeschichte
so hat jetzt der historiker jan mathieu
seine langjährige forschungsarbeit in
einem buch zusammengefasst alpenflora
berg ansichten wasserfälle gletscher für
gutbetuchte kulturreisende im
achtzehnten jahrhundert eine neue und
faszinierende welt auch für maler
allerdings oft ohne dass diese sich
tatsächlich einen 4000 ernährten
ganz anders die neue gattung alpina
touristen die alpinisten die briten
verharmlosten die alpen als playground
of europe europa spielplatz oder erhoben
sie zu kathedralen der erde
alpinisten wenden sich auf dem gipfel
zuweilen dem schöpfer nahe doch die
gefährliche leidenschaft forderte immer
mehr todesopfer und führte zu einer
moralischen diskussion so auch nach der
erstbesteigung des materials 1865 als
vier mitglieder des teams beim abstieg
ums leben kamen
gleichzeitig wollte immer mehr menschen
bequem in die höhe gelangen
große bahnprojekte wurden verwirklicht
wie die zahnradbahn die ab 1871 auf die
rigi fuhr als erster bergmann europas
die alpen waren auch rückzugsgebiet für
den notfall im réduit tief im fels hätte
die wehrhafte schweiz dem fallen dem
zweiten weltkrieg trotzen sollen
und auch dies müssen die alpen erdulden
gigantische staumauern die struktur und
natur des gebirges verändern
die wasserkraft eine unerschöpfliche
energiequelle trumpfte alpenländer stets
im konflikt mit den schutz des
berggebiet der zunehmend an bedeutung
gewinnt
heute jedoch droht die ganze alpenregion
zum freizeit eldorado zu verkommen
es wird gerodet geklettert gekraxelt und
geschaukelt was die seile halten und
nach jedem sommer warnt der berg weil
die gletscher ungebremst dahinschmelzen
abdeckungen als reine symptombekämpfung
alpen was wird blues auf